Missy wrote in what are some outdated or
just simply dumb examples of what it
means to be manly in modern society I
have many thoughts about this pad number
one men crying right I mean the idea
that if you cry you're not manly
being in touch with your emotions now is
the sign of not being manly and by the
way but we're conceding here that the
whole concept of being manly is
absolutely ridiculous but we're
accepting it in order to be able to
fully answer the question that's number
one
what about treating animals badly like
being rough with a with a dog or a cat
because you're a man as opposed to like
being being gentle and caring to animals
how is that how is that considered the
sign of manliness that you're going to
break and by the way treating your
significant other whether your
significant other is is male or female
the idea of in public sort of being this
aggressively rude domineering man to
your significant other is that right
that that's how you portray being alpha
yeah I think strong people don't put
others down they lift them up and I
think that you know goes to this idea
that just because another person or an
animal is smaller than you that doesn't
mean you don't get to treat them with
any the same respect that you would of
someone your own side I totally agree
and along those lines bumper stickers
that have just just like ridiculous
childish messages on them and pick it it
doesn't have to be political right like
just pick whatever you want we don't
even have to give examples but the idea
that as an adult in order to assert your
strength you would put some kind of
ridiculous crude offensive aggressive
demeaning message on a bumper sticker on
your car and drive around with that as
sort of like a billboard of what it is
that you believe in society and dammit
people better not mess with you as a
result how about bragging you know it
seems like that's such a childish thing
to do now not so much maybe you know
manly versus not manly because when
people talk often about you know their
finances or the people that they're
dating or just how strong
they are they're trying to play
themselves up and I think there is a
masculine element to that interesting
but I think that's you know starting to
be just seen as obnoxious now yeah I
mean it's sort of like the art of the
humblebrag is what's become more in now
which is sort of subtly communicating
and this actually kind of relates to
that book the aspirational class that we
talked about with Elizabeth Kurt halket
where it's like the way that you
communicate elitism or finance economic
stability or success in modern society
has changed and along those same lines
the ways in which one might communicate
sort of manliness or masculinity have
probably evolved as well I think that
the concept of like a girlie alcoholic
drink is kind of dumb like if you like a
drink that for whatever reason is is
visually a pink drink because it might
have grapefruit in it or whatever the
case may be
how are you less masculine as a result
you might just like the flavor or even
just wearing pink now so yeah I mean a
lot of men are not willing to wear pink
because it's associated with feminism
but more more and more you are seeing
men wearing texture yeah at least again
this might be that divide between where
in the United States you're living but
in New York City in Boston it's sort of
like not really a big deal you do own a
pink shirt that you sometimes wear on
the show I haven't gotten to that point
numerous yet I guess I'm just I'm not as
comfortable with my masculinity I have
pink shirt salmond purple you know
whatever it doesn't doesn't really
matter the other thing by the way before
we get off of this the food thing where
like when you see people be critical of
the size of someone else's food portions
I don't know where you thought I was
going there pat pat looked up concern
for a second like saying what what a
tiny burger like that dude that's what
you're eating man uh.when who cares you
know you know what I've had you know
whether I just had a snack you don't
know what's going this it's the dumbest
thing and when you this is when I speak
to high school students a lot of times
there will be questions about what
lesson might I have or what did I really
learn from high school and very often
I'll say I know it doesn't seem like it
right now but the stuff you think
matters right now and the stuff you
think will be important for your entire
life
it's
not going to be and I know that you
won't fully understand that for probably
another eight to ten years but try to at
least consider that the things that seem
really important right now are not
actually going to be that important for
you and I don't know if you started
realizing that Pappa for when I look
back to high school which was longer ago
for me than it was for you almost
nothing that people cared about then
makes a difference in adulthood or just
even the functions and events going on
at the school seems like the most
important thing like you everyone had
this idea of having a prom that was you
know something out of the movies but
then when you're a few years removed
from it what does that really matter
yeah I went to my 10-year we're kind of
getting off track here but I went to my
10-year high school reunion few years
ago and there were definitely you could
tell who peaked in high school so to
speak and the people who were at their
peak in high school
are noticeably generally speaking not
exactly doing as well now I'm not sure
if you're experiencing that with your
high school class to some degree well
you don't know if you've hit your peak
until you're on a downward trajectory
yeah that's true so I guess I'm gonna
have to wait a few years
all right well Pat's going to get back
to us on that okay good questions this
week thanks so much to everybody who
wrote in you can submit your questions
however you want social media email
whatever Missy Lisa and Ilya did all of
those use all of those methods methods
we've got a tremendous bonus show for
you today but I'm out of time I can't
tell you what's on it but trust me it's
a really good one